-Our first guest tonight i
an Academy Award-nominated
and Emmy Award-winning actress
you know from her work in
the "The Wizard of Lies,"
"Dangerous Liaisons"
and "Batman Returns."
She just received a Golden Globe
nomination for Best Actres
for her role in "French Exit,"
which is in theaters
on February 12th.
Let's take a look.
-I spoke to you about this as
possibility for seven years,
and then an
eventuality for three.
What did you think
was going to happen?
Frances, what -- what
was your plan?
-My plan was to die
before the money ran out,
but I kept and keep not dying,
and...here I am.
-Please welcome to the sho
Michelle Pfeiffer.
Hello, Michelle.
Thanks for being here.
-Hi. Thanks for having me.
-So, I want to ask -- You know
a lot of actors, you know,
couldn't do a great deal of work
this last year,
when everything shut down,
but you also have
a fragrance company.
And I'm wondering if you
were able to sort of
throw yourself into that as so
much else was unavailable.
-I feel really lucky
that not only
did my fragrance company -
henryrose.com --
not only did it survive
this past year,
but, yes, I had
something to, you know,
get up and do every day.
And it was great, because it
really gave me an opportunit
to really get hyper-focuse
on the business.
-And do you also have a very -
Do you feel like
you are someone who has
a very good nose for fragrance
Because it would strike me
that that's an
important element of it.
-I actually do.
But I had to learn, though
You know, the sort of language
of a perfumer
is very different,
and I would start with say--
You know, I would start with
saying, "Oh, I don't know.
I think it smells
a little bit orange."
And they would say, "No, no, no.
Don't tell me what
you think it smells like.
Tell me what you --
Tell me what it reminds you of
What do you think
of when you smell it?"
And I learned to
say things like...
[ Sniffs ]
"Oh, I don't know.
It smells like...
baby-doll head."
And so, you know,
I've learned how
to sort of speak their language.
And, as it turns out, I actually
do have a pretty good nose
Good thing.
-Yeah.
I imagine if you were, like,
congested all the time,
you should probably
find a different gig.
This movie is really wonderful
and it seems like
maybe something we haven't
seen from you before.
As the clip maybe
explains pretty well,
you play a socialite
who runs out of money
and then leaves
New York for Paris.
Did you know right away when you
were reading it how good it was?
-I did.
And, you know,
that doesn't happen every --
That doesn't happen very often
And I -- Patrick deWitt
is such a wonderful writer
and he has such a unique voice
And he writes with --
You know, he sort of --
All of his characters
use comedy as a coping tool,
and they're sort of dark
and funny and absurd
and, yet, you know, these craz
sort of eccentric characters
And, yet,
somehow by the end of it,
you end up being able to
relate to them
and seeing yourselves
in their --
you know, in their journey
And I just --
And I loved this character
She was unlike anything I ha
ever read or, you know,
anyone I've ever met.
Very complicated, very kind of
takes-no-prisoners attitude,
and, you know, a bit, kind o
coarse and curt at times,
but, underneath it,
a kind of a fragility.
And it was, you know,
a lot of fun to play somebod
who just speaks their mind
all the time.
-I did read you were a littl
scared about taking on the role.
What was it that gave you
any hesitation?
-Well, I think there's som
parts that are closer to you
and this one wasn't at all
And she was from a world tha
I wasn't that familiar with.
I had some friends, I had
sort of brushes with this worl
and this kind of woman
throughout my life,
because I had friends
who grew up in this world.
But -- And I was also kind of --
I knew that it was going t
take a lot out of me,
and I was a little bit
depleted when I started it
But the thing about
great material is,
it kind of just infuses
you every day,
and you don't --
It just sort of --
You wake up every morning, and
it kind of carries you through
And we had such an amazing cas
in working with --
Aza Jacobs was incredible
and Lucas Hedges
and Valerie Mahaffey.
Mahaffey?
So, it was just --
It was a real joy.
-You -- I'm not the first person
to make an observation
that there is a character
in this film that is
a cat, a black cat.
You famously played -- and
fantastically, I should note -
played Catwoman.
Was the cat community excite
to work with you again?
-Thrilled.
-Yes.
-Yes. Yeah.
You know, and I didn't really --
I know -- I have this kind o
running theme,
and didn't sort of even
realize it until, actually
journalists started
asking me about it.
But I do love cats.
I have a cat.
She's not as well behaved
as the cats that we work with.
I was -- One of my
first questions for Aza was,
"Number one, talk to
me about the tone of this,
because I felt like
that was critical.
And then
my second question was,
"Okay, what about this cat
And how are you going to
deal with that?"
And it's so
funny and fascinating
that the characters in the piece
just find it completely normal
that there's a talking cat
-How many cats do you thin
you worked with
to play the one cat
in the movie?
-Primarily just two.
-Okay.
-And they were
amazing and really sweet
and just kind of normal,
you know, not standoffish.
And they were lovely.
And I guess there was
another one that I didn't know
until recently
that was a tiny bit edgier
I'm not going to say mean.
But they only brought
that cat out in one scene,
where there's a bit of
a confrontation with
Frances and Small Frank.
-So it was sort of the
emotional tenor of that scen
called for that cat.
-Exactly.
-Wow.
And, you know, as with animals
they have numerous animals
to play the same part,
and they are usually
better at different things
-Well, I thought
they were all great,
but all paled
in comparison to you.
Thank you so much for making the
time and being with us today
-I'm so happy.
Nice to be on the show.
-"French Exit"
will be in theaters
on Friday, February 12th.